[Music]
four o'clock in the morning i wake up
have my caffeine in the morning four
o'clock in the morning but by the way
that's the magic hour that four o'clock
in the morning is when no one else is up
so no one else is bothering you and you
can focus on whatever work you have to
get done i'm sending these electronic
mails those things right i've heard of
them
those things and then by 4 30 4 45 i'm
doing some sort of cardio so in this
case i come out here open these garage
doors uh it's still dark outside so it's
just me and a whole bunch of blair witch
things that are happening out there in
the woods
and i jump on this thing uh i do this
and then i'll have breakfast and then i
will go do all my strength and
conditioning training at a gym for about
an hour and then i'll go to set so total
workout time for all the dudes that are
like i could look like that at home
right now how much run time cardio and
strength do you do a day
between cardio
strength and resistance training
stretching maybe about an hour and 45
minutes
i want to know the very first thing you
do first thing i do is look at my phone
oh you look at the phone first okay
that's interesting yeah i do that too i
i look at facebook right to see what's
going on in the world right right and i
and i check
uh my messages i look at messenger and
whatsapp and how long how many minutes
would you say you spend you know it
depends on what's going on in the world
on a good calm day right um
it'll probably be no more than a few
minutes right i was never a morning
person um max is definitely turning me
into a morning person
max
um
is like a pterodactyl it's like i didn't
know a human could make those noises
right and then do you take a shower
or you're gonna you work out first the
better strategy is to work out and then
you shower
what is your morning routine usually
before the sun comes up
i
offer myself
to something greater than myself
if it's for one minute 20 seconds or 10
minutes i at least stop in that space in
my house every morning
i have a little meditation space where i
just go i have beautiful spiritual
readings there i light my three candles
there
daily word or something and i express
to this greater energy field than i
that i don't want to be alone as i move
out into the world
[Music]
richard people want to know what does
your morning routine look like i wake up
really early every day
and i play tennis with somebody who's a
lot younger and a lot fitter than me and
we play singles and you know we give it
everything we can and you know end up
you know sweating big time and having a
lot of fun at this you know as well and
then if the wind is up you know go for a
kite surf um
uh you know kiting's um you know a
lovely way just to get a get away from
you know the mobile phones and and and
just get you know get out on the sea
um
and uh and then you know after that you
know come back have a you know have a
sort of nice healthy breakfast generally
sometimes uh you know sometimes
not so healthy then i'm ready for the
day
what is your morning routine like what
do you do when you first get up in the
morning you know believe it or not i
still you know i read a physical paper
every single morning which one i read
the wall street journal every morning i
read the new york times online
and you know i still i'm very particular
about having my tea it's very english
you know i grew up in india
so having my tea and
i'm vegetarian so i need to get my
protein so i always have an omelette in
the morning with toast
tea
and read my paper so i do that every
morning what time do you wake up
6 30 to 7 so that's when i do it
i just have a simple routine to get up
early in the morning
i believe what ted turner said early
debate early to rise work like hell and
advertise and so this is what i believe
in so i go into bed early it's around 10
o'clock and i wake up at 4 o'clock in
the morning
which is 6 hours of sleep that's all you
need you need more than just sleep a
little faster and then i just get going
you know i mean then i read
yeah
i read the newspaper i read articles
they go on the internet and they read uh
and then by the time comes six o'clock i
get on my bike i ride down to the gym i
work out for an hour then i ride back
again at my breakfast so this is a
routine just to get the day going before
i ever go to the office a big boy starts
in serious growth so it's a routine
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here